boa noite gestão pra mim é exemplo
presença e olhar e acho que hoje a gente
vive nesta era digital que ela tem as
duas coisas ao mesmo tempo ela nos
aproxima e ela nos distancia ela nos
aproxima porque a gente usa a rede pra
aprender pra pesquisar para fazer amigos
para enviar mensagens que
instantaneamente são lidas em qualquer
lugar do mundo
ela nos distancia que a gente perde um
pouco da emoção
vou dar um exemplo se eu decidi agora
envia uma mensagem e no final eu quero
enviar uma gargalhada
eu usaria várias vezes a letra k ousaria
as letras é a h
agora se nós estamos nesse grupo de
amigos e de repente a conversa é boa e
nós terminamos com uma gargalhada
o efeito de uma palavra dita e de uma
palavra escrita é completamente
diferente e eu digo isso pra eu fiz essa
comparação para a gente voltar os três
pilares da gestão exemplo presença e
olhar e eu fico imaginando quantas
idéias quantas propostas quanto às
soluções estão nas nossas equipes ea
gente não assim planta da empresa porque
o gestor não está próximo dessas equipes
e aí eu fico imaginando é a presença
desse gestor local de trabalho deles
porque quando nós nos encontramos entre
gestores diretores
quando você pergunta sobre a equipe a
primeira palavra que vem à cabeça são
números
eu tenho 10 20 30 50 500 mil
colaboradores
agora quando nós chegamos na ponta e nós
vamos olhar lá pra aquele que está lá no
último degrau da escala da nossa empresa
nós chegamos por aí perguntamos para ele
quem é seu chefe
quem são seus chefes ele lembra o nome
ele lembra o cargo e ele lembra a vez em
que o diretor ou gerente esteve no local
de trabalho dele
se é que ele esteve nos nossos
colaboradores nós somos únicos
nós somos pessoas únicas e eu fico
imaginando a cena de um gestor pelos
corredores da empresa pelas salas no
café ou mesmo na rua quando local de
trabalho foi na rua
a imagem que este colaborador tem vai
ficar na memória dele para a vida toda
e dificilmente as pesquisas que a gente
encomenda e elabora vão conseguir captar
completamente a imagem que ficou deste
gestor junto à sua equipe e quando nós
trabalhamos agora com a mistura de uma
geração mais antiga de colaboradores com
a nova essa geração que em quieta
instável inteligente rápida que é pedido
é que quase todo dia que há respostas
imediatas à presença de um gestor junto
a eles com certeza vai potencializar a
energia tanto para a felicidade de toda
a equipe quanto para o sucesso da
empresa
ele ficou lembrando também quando nós
estamos propondo mudanças nas nossas
empresas
a primeira primeira idéia que vem à
cabeça
contrataram uma pessoa especializada ou
uma empresa para começar a fazer o
projeto e nós esquecemos que quem sabe
mais o que faz é quem faz todos os dias
aquele trabalho é quem está na ponta
essas pessoas normalmente são esquecidas
essas equipes são esquecidas e na medida
em que a gente puxar essas equipes foram
vilas nós conseguiremos que o resultado
da mudança que a gente queira será muito
melhor
ele vai ser muito melhor exatamente
porque essas pessoas se sentirão parte e
com certeza o que a gente gostaria que
acontecesse vai acontecer muito melhor
porque nós temos a participação deles
essa altura boa parte de vocês deve
estar imaginando o que o diretor está na
base da pirâmide vamos chamar assim de
uma empresa é uma utopia
vou recorrer à o escritor e educador
pernambucano paulo freire falou muito
sobre a utopia e ele dizia que eu tô pia
não é algo não realizável utopia é um
sonho possível é você compreender que a
realidade não é está sendo e ela pode
vir a ser transformada e aí a primeira
alegação que se ouve dentro de uma
empresa quando quando se pede que os
gestores os diretores cheguem na base é
falta de tempo
só que quando acontece uma crise no
escritório numa filial ou no mesmo
departamento qual é a primeira decisão
tomada pela matriz pela gestão máxima
vamos formar um grupo vamos pra lá vamos
ouvir vamos tentar minimizar essa crise
de repente o tempo apareceu o tempo que
não existia antes ele apareceu naquele
momento eu arrisco a dizer que se nós
tivéssemos feito esta esta passagem por
aquele departamento por aquela filial
por aquele é aquele escritório em crise
antes provavelmente a crise não teria
existido ela teria sido minimizado com
certeza porque na medida em que a
presença é do gestor está junto aos seus
a um equilíbrio de forças e uma e uma e
uma e uma delegação de importância você
é importante eu também sou importante
para vocês
então naquele momento em que você é é é
você discutir de igual para igual você
conversa de igual para igual
a reação do tudo da sua equipe é
completamente diferente no momento em
que a gente cobra muito das nossas
equipes e inovação e criatividade
eu fico imaginando é que o primeiro a
dar o exemplo de criatividade e inovação
do gestor
o primeiro exemplo tem que partir dele
inovar é sair de onde ele está
inovar ele ir para
o ambiente de trabalho dos colaboradores
em todas as suas instâncias e ele
partilhar de momentos em dia marcado
senhora marcadas em palestra marcada
porque nesse dia ele estando junto ele
vai encontrar a realidade da empresa ele
vai sentir que realmente a empresa está
precisando que as pessoas estão
precisando
se ele fizer aquela famosa visita
oficial pouco vai adiantar porque a
realidade não será aquela que as pessoas
estão esperando e ele também não colherá
não partilhará ele não ele não
conseguirá saber exatamente qual é
opinião das pessoas o que elas conversam
que elas de estudos discutem quais são
os seus anseios quais são as suas
histórias e aí eu volto a paulo freire
que é preciso diminuir a distância entre
o que se diz eo que se faz
acredito que diminuindo a distância
entre o que a gente diz o que a gente
faz
nós conseguiremos ter equipes mais
alegres mais felizes mais colaborativas
nós conseguiremos ter cidadãos
colaboradores que eles vão mudar não só
o resultado da empresa mas
fundamentalmente o lugar onde eles vivem
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]